that's good now here we go we are
talking about ugly dogs this morning
this is Bonnie pleased that you're not
ugly are you no well bonnie is a rescue
dog and and fifty five percent of dogs
apparently they're being dumped in
shelters are being dumped because they
aren't pretty enough for Instagram or
Twitter and fashionable dogs like pubs
and Minister dachshunds are the most
popular and the runts of the litter
waiting years to be adoptable Claire is
here hello Claire people must go for
Bonnie straight away rather than talking
to you because I apologize look that's
you native bonnie is camera-ready
and this is a real problem isn't isn't
it clear because bonnie is a rescue dog
and do we think she was dumped because
of the way she looked I think it's more
to do with people choosing dogs over
their looks and not actually realizing
what comes with dog ownership so I think
Bonnie looks quite cute but probably the
family that had her before didn't
realize how much work it takes and I
think one of the big problems that we
have at the moment is the celebrities
and social media who have him these dogs
that look trendy and people don't
realize that they still need to be fed
they still need to be walked they still
need a lot of care and a lot of training
our pugs are the most popular and they
come with some of the worst health
problems and can be really expensive
it's the likes of Staffordshire Bull
Terriers greyhounds Rottweilers boxers
as well that have being ditched perhaps
because the way they look but as you
said a boxer needs a lot of exercise and
a lot of attention and that's catching
dog owners out as well I think they they
all get a bad rep actually if you take
Staffordshire Bull Terriers I think
traditionally they were always called
the nanny dog they're brilliant with
children and families they actually have
a bad reputation because of the types of
owners that have had them before and I
think that people like greyhounds a lot
of them from when they were being used
for racing and then get bit and then
they're retired and but I think people
really need to look into the breed that
they that they they've seen on social
media or they've seen
bought by their favorite celebrity and
actually researched what's going I'm
sorry I just got fainted because Bonnie
can't decide whether to stand up or sit
down I mean that's the ultimate downward
dog lots of you getting in touch this
morning because of course some people
may call them ugly but beauty is in the
eye of the owner lots of you sending in
your pictures of your dogs this morning
we got a few examples to show you here
we go let's have a look who have we got
here this from Stuart James I mean this
is who is this this is Bonnie a stuffy
another Bonnie popular name for dogs Kay
Guerrieri this is her bull terrier
stuffy across rescue pup very
comfortable in his own skin I mean it's
it's dogs like this that are in families
and yes alright they might not be the
prettiest but look at them
look at the kids they love their dogs
hmm it's all about temperament as well
isn't it rather than looks absolutely I
mean one of the things that you'll
notice is the lot of the dogs that end
up in rescue are the dark colors yeah
and people say that's because they don't
photograph yeah we heard I heard about
that with black cats I'm Claire thank
you so much coming in and raising
awareness of this and if you aren't
gonna get a dog look into getting a
rescue dog those dogs that need home
like Bonnie I'm Bonnie you're so cute
just gonna say a quick goodbye
it's about while I'm talking to Bonnie
it's time for the weather Isabel's gonna
see us out coming